Now if the Oscars are a delicious cupcake,
the fashion might be the decadent icing.
You know you heard me.
You can't have one without the other.
Look at her.
I did.
You know, I was like, I need a dress on right now.
And we wanna see how well we remember some of
the red carpet's greatest hits.
Oh boy.
Are you guys ready to play that game?
Let's do it.
Let's go.
Yes, it's time to play Guess That Dress!
Yes!
Here's how it's gonna work.
We'll check out a stunning Oscar dress from Oscar history
and see if we can guess that dress.
Are you ready to play?
Good, all right, up first,
and I do not know these answers,
I haven't seen these.
I already know.
I already know it.
Lupita Nyong'o.
Exactly.
Is it Miu Miu or Prada, one of the two,
but it was that Lupita Nyong'o.
Lupita Nyong'o, yes.
Nischelle and I are gonna kick your butt.
All right.
I don't know, we'll see what happens.
All right, next.
Next let's guess this dress.
Halle Berry.
Oh, Halle Berry.
That was 2000, when she won, yeah.
Yes.
2002.
The next iconic dress is this.
Ooh, ooh, is that Barbra Streisand?
This is Cher, Cher.
Cher.
Cher?
Faye Dunaway?
Cher, it was, it was.
Next, guess this dress.
Gwyneth Paltrow.
Oh, Gwyneth Paltrow.
Gwyneth, yes, iconic.
Oh, Gwyneth.
I mean, really don't wanna
sit next to her anymore.
I mean, she shouts out every answer.
But you know, to me, the best Gwyneth dress
was that white sheath Tom Ford with the cape.
I don't think anyone has looked better
at an Oscar ever than her.
Okay, and finally, our final dress, who is it?
Angelina Jolie, the leg!
Angelina Jolie, the leg.
The leg.
(audience applauding)
That leg was everywhere.
Everybody was doing that leg.
Yeah, that moment became super iconic.
Well, Kevin, Nischelle, I can't wait to recap with you guys
and see what really happened on the big night.
And I just, I'd love the opportunity
to be able to do this with you guys every time.
Same.
More awards shows,
because we just have so much fun doing them.
Kevin Frazier and Nischelle Turner,
obviously, you can watch them every night as I do
on Entertainment Tonight, and we all do.
Yay.
That's right, baby.
And don't forget, the Oscars air on ABC
this Sunday, March 27th at 8:00 PM Eastern.
We hope everyone has a great night.
(upbeat music)